on pourrait dire que l'économie
française aujourd'hui c'est un peu comme
le coyote de bibi plat dans le dessin
animé où il court au dessus du vide sans
se rendre compte qu'il est au dessus du
vide il ya eu tellement de dépenses
publiques pour soutenir l'économie que
en fait c'est trop et ça fausse
complètement les prix et la perception
de la réalité
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont touché
dès le chômage partiel est exposée il ya
eu énormément de prêts qui ont été
offerts aux entreprises avec l'épée j'ai
eu et j'ai l'impression que j'ai t-il
gouvernement c'est pas tellement de de
sauver l'économie c'est plutôt de faire
en sorte qu'ils aient pas d'explosion de
faillite avant l'élection présidentielle
c'est à dire qu'ils font en sorte de
balancer de l'argent public uniquement
pour éviter la grande purge qui manquera
pas d'arriver parce que comme le sinel
comme site destiné à tout à l'heure
en 2020 il ya eu 38 % de faillite en moi
que 2019 c'est à dire que désormais ce
qu'ils auraient dû faire faillite n'ont
pas fait faillite avec le cowboy avec
les aides qui ont été apportés par
l'état elles vont en profiter et donc
tous ces entreprises là plus ou celles
qui vont faire faillite à cause du
confinement
un jour ou l'autre il va falloir payer
la note et je pense que le l'unique
objectif du gouvernement c'est de
ballons c'est de l'argent public de
retarder les remboursements du pge pour
faire en sorte que cette grande crise ne
se produise pas avant l'élection
présidentielle 2022 sinon ils sont sûrs
d'être des perdants ils vont en faire en
sorte de la déplacer après mais il n'y a
pas de réelle volonté de rendre
l'économie française plus productifs
plus efficace hormis la baisse des
impôts de production qui est une bonne
chose mais je veux dire là on parle un
peu trop de dépenses publiques et pas
assez d'eux et pas assez de baisses d
impôts de bas étage rappelle que la
france a le taux de prélèvements
obligatoires le plus élevé des pelles
ocde donc avec de tel boulet au pied il
faut pas espérer que les entreprises
françaises performe il faut pas espérer
qu'on ait de la croissance genre 6% de
croissance en 2021 comme le premier
bruit de l'onerc un chiffrement délirant
il faut pas espérer de bonnes
performances avec de tels et puis aussi
avec toute la bureaucratie qu'emi avait
toutes les normes environnementales la
lutte conter passoires thermiques qui va
en fait contre contribué à restreindre
l'offre de logement
donc tout ça c'est des éléments
bureaucratique et dette publics
extrêmement nocif qui ont pour seul
objectif de maintenir l'économie à bout
de bras jusqu'en 2022 et c'est tout
[Musique]